late at night I get inspired watch nice
stuff thank you so much
come on in sit sit sit yeah of course
no I'll take I'll take a coffee winning
your chance yeah I think so him and I
are very friendly but I don't remember
yeah he's such a good dude
so what's going on in your world that
was crazy it was awesome and then you
know after that happened course all
these companies are eat you know I'll
bring stuff over little money for money
offering like booty off missing you know
it's a little overwhelming
it's no I'm used to being so you know
it's getting offered all these deals for
you know it's kind of keeping pushing
and then during the season out like 40
guys they work with Darren retainer and
travel city to city watch film with the
guys we work with them and on the off
season comes as our season I see thank
you but that's what do you do yeah so I
helped him with the workouts for four
years now
in all the videos around myself you can
swim kind of do the stuff that you used
to do kind of things just like all
leveling up like similar stuff to make
video to create awareness yes eight
million news news yep well Kevin watch
them all fifteen times and easy just
access one person and who are you
characters you have a separate company
you guys
disrupt nice I think
the toughest thing senior you can you
take on so many clients so I like 56 DMV
guys first you think it's a great thing
knowing this even starts you know I have
to every single game you talk to these
guys you know every problem they have
it's on you so you know early in the
season ago of course well I think I
think you know anything that's not
scalable like vaynermedia like I have a
hundred fifty to two hundred million
dollars worth of clients running through
the main or X machine but I don't deal
with any of that because I was ok with
building equity and other people so I
know what to me because you started by
starting with that was the equity and if
you started with us and then if you
started with us and us and I said well
all you have to do Derrick Morgan and
Braxton Miller and all these guys that
switched over to Boehner it started with
me but then they're like oh AJ's good
and he's even more available than Gary
and [ __ ] it all I want is to work on my
mid-range jumper and have somebody
answer the [ __ ] phone every time on
the spot so it you know I think what you
need to do is a couple things if you
want to keep building that business and
you view that as a leverage to the other
things which it is nobody's [ __ ] with
you if like black ops had me coming
through and going three for 39 from the
field you know like like the key for you
is to figure out who else yeah and
really really and not be worried and the
biggest thing that a guy like you
worries about is he goes and does his
own thing and and you just have to be
okay with that
of course you have to you have to worry
that's how I feel I'm thrilled if babban
wants to go do this for Will Smith
cuz I know I'm great yeah and that's all
you have to do you have to be great at
what you do and like be good dude and
like and some people will some people
don't want to be the guy I don't know
him I don't know Sally who's the third
one that you'll decide to add after this
meeting some will some won't so you know
some won't just because like [ __ ] it
even though I kind of do like this is my
guy or like they just like being number
two three four or five six
but you can't be crippled by cuz it's
what happens you know once he's got the
relationship with Russ and LeBron and
Schlemmer on well then it's then he can
just say I'm out yeah but that can't
stop you from building a business
otherwise you have pregnant and then
that if you like actually have that vibe
with him all of a sudden like either you
ever said he'll go or the next guy will
go or not go period that's just a binary
decision you'd almost be happy
you know it's like being a coach you do
watch Bill and Bill 30 for 30 yet yeah
you did perfect did you notice how
[ __ ] Bill Parcells was setting Bill
Belichick up to be a coach good and
guess what he meant him and if it's not
him him him could be even better at it
than you and that's okay you just want
to be the tree so that's it man that's
the game that's the game and you got to
start putting energy against it yeah
which means which means which means
those videos need to start you know
really like putting people on here's my
thing the thing that you need to figure
out is do you want to use the training
as like do you always like for me they
like it's actually the world I'm living
in now like vaynermedia is actually not
smart in the same way that your training
business is not smart anymore but it's
actually very smart like like to me like
I hate that I have an agency and have to
deal with all this [ __ ] but long term
when I buy Pony and and all the next
generation of basketball players are
wearing pony off the court it will all
work out because of this and I would
have never been able to do that by
myself I would have been able to make
twenty five million dollars a year
speaking and being Mike and writing
books and being me and charging a
hundred thousand dollars a day to
I have three our versions of this cool
but that's not 15 billion yeah and so
that's it and there's a lot of risks and
emotions and [ __ ] that comes along with
that wouldn't deal with people but CA
was built like like William Morris was
built like people have done it by
building out you know other
personalities you mean you personally in
your thing at this point
I would I would there's no right answer
like here's what I know Under Armour
offer you ten million dollars and you
can't work with any other brand so you
do it so it's just it's just a just an
auction right like if everybody's
offering a hundred well then you want to
take all seven hundreds but if
somebody's offering a million I mean
then you know there's no right answer
here's what I would say just never lie
and everything can work it's actually a
great piece of advice it might not be
fun to say to KD something or mellow or
crisp ah I might not be fun but if you
never lie you're in a great spot you
want to eat they know that you wanted
your job I would say this it all starts
to start starts and stops with a thing
that got you there just coz I've gotten
bigger I don't stop interacting with
people I don't start I don't I don't big
time I want to know people like that
will never go away because that's what
got me here so what got you the here is
like you were good at your craft and
guys trust in you and and you don't want
to give that up for five million dollars
you're right
so JP but but but you still wanna make
you still and you should which is why
the lying is the key whatever you decide
that's what you decided whatever it is
it is like I invested in go
which was a Foursquare competitor when
the five years ago when all those
Foursquare check-in Bing happen I
invested in koala but told all my
clients to use Foursquare because it was
better that's why I sit here today it's
very important you might get fifteen
million dollars from adidas you just
better tell them listen if [ __ ] this
classroom Duke that comes out and three
of them want to work with me if one of
them's [ __ ] ankle I think fits better
into a [ __ ] you know a six shoe I'm
gonna tell them like like if you know
like like [ __ ] uh my home I don't I
guess I don't mind probably brought me
those Marvel Panther like if I want to
rock those then I can do it and when I
go to LA this weekend I want to rock
those you know along with mine and but
that's because I told him like look I'm
still gonna come through for you for
what you want everything you possibly
think okay well you can tell the same
thing in a different place well I think
I mean look you do whatever you want I
mean I think attention is the most
important asset but I think you have to
be smart right like I'd rather you do
something with you know with [ __ ]
barstool than Rolling Stone let go where
the culture is you know but what's good
about wrong stones that gets you into
new eyes that don't see you on Instagram
so
okay I literally made a buddy I didn't
think it was gonna be much no it's the
Kardashians everyone's wearing it when
you say next thing I know like talk me
through that because that's an important
thing for me to understand to give you
advice I wasn't let go I just put this
on Shopify yep
Alabama was so smart and then the next
thing I know I've done some money I'm
struggling so now I have a team of two
sorry so I we've done like eight or nine
different releases so they released
doing a collab with Mickey Mouse
analysis and who runs it yeah I mean
it's you know here's what I can say
other you find either you find young
talent that is so pumped to have
autonomy and run [ __ ] and you keep a
hundred percent and the trade is you're
putting youngsters on looking to meet
people they're learning and then they
can decide what the [ __ ] they want to do
at 28 or you give up 20 to 50 percent
two people know what the [ __ ] they're
doing and you're not guessing you don't
see you don't think they can do it
they've been doing it for 14 years I
think both work like supreme school you
know it's more cool Nike just depends
what you think is cool like
you know converse is more cool than
supreme make more money you know but but
for now what's great about cool is you
can get there you know you're either in
control you're not also your Jana B
check
yeah okay that's that's right to say no
today you know I get it that's how
people make real money though
Huck said no to a billion dollars just
gotta figure out how long you want to be
in it yeah you know it's just it's about
risk tolerance just more about do you
know yourself right like Chris Tallis is
the right way to like look at it like on
paper and a textbook it's actually
different than that it's actually like
what the [ __ ] are you up to here's what
I know about you
without I don't know anything about you
but like here's what I know about you I
think you really struggle with the idea
of making 10 million but being known as
a poor and a sellout and never being
able to play after four years from today
yeah okay well good let's start with
that I don't know so I don't know us to
tell you see I leave I do I think the
reason I am Who I am is cuz I leave so
much money on the table man I was 34
years old when I left Wine Library I
owned
nothing Eldar you perfect I was 34 when
I left my dad's business I built it for
him I own zero percent of it which means
the bank and the world saw me as being
worthless I never paid myself more than
$70,000 a year I was 34 I think you're I
think you're you may overthink this
moment and and and I think that may lead
to bad decisions my fears selling Ross
you know we kind of gave you this
platform of course that's memories fear
shipping right I guess what there's some
kid coming up right behind you
then it's thrilled to take 80% of what
you take to just do basketball and what
ten times harder new because they don't
have all this other opportunity course I
can really really really help and would
happily through all these conversations
I have the real thoughts about this [ __ ]
there's a reason there's not an accident
that I'm gonna be the guy and it's based
on this on the right way of thinking
about things and it starts with what the
[ __ ] do you want cuz I want to buy the
Jets I got to do everything right yeah
if you want to [ __ ] smoke weed and
you know Jamaica and bang hot chicks
well then you can just sell out now
that's easy look and by the way by the
way that sounds great too it's like like
I'm I'm not judging one's ambitions
right now is the time you decide where
you want this thing to end up and you
work backwards well then then you need
to really make it all about that because
they have the leverage not you period
that's not even close I think just the
base battle is you know so right now
from the top face with kids the country
top college kids of course everybody yet
everybody and you know you don't charge
I said hey Bart watch it so you know
there's like that dry period that's not
during this season dad and you don't
charge them you don't charge them
because you think they'll buy with it
then they can look
yeah but guess what you're building a
brand your best old business model is
different now you don't need to do as
many pro bono meaning meaning you're so
[ __ ] cool because of last summer what
happened on Instagram and YouTube that
you don't need that they're just gonna
go with you anyway mm-hmm I would double
down on [ __ ] LeBron and Melo because
that's why you'll get them not because
you were nice to them I'm very aware
it's even less about like being cool and
like getting the girl to come to you or
the guy it's more about you do it for
LeBron and and Russ like when they come
out like sure Rick was nice to them in
high school in college but now that
they're in a league they're gonna go
with the coolest brand mm-hmm
like this is recruiting you were the
nicest coach you're the best friend you
took care of their mama but I'm gonna go
Duke brand always wins
that's why Boehner Sports is gonna win
we haven't even started and we're
already dating we have a guy in the
green room in our first year like it's
it's gonna be a problem
so gc7 I sleep it's just that I work so
hard the other 18 it's not about how
much you sleep you know cuz you're not
in the right spot yet you're yeah which
I'm the reason I'm good is cuz I'm a
piece so one of the problems is to the
games right yeah west cuz I respect that
what what what time do you go to sleep 3
yeah
and what time do you get up
you need to be smart don't be stupid
change your world
you're a guy that goes to sleep at 3 or
4 it's ok if you start at 11 I'm being
dead [ __ ] serious yeah and then you
just tell somebody that's cool that
you're judging me dick but I wouldn't
sleep it forward you went to sleep at 11
I gotta get this call
[Music]